Boulton is a Song of Ice and Fire fan
theory that claims that Roose Bolton is
a long-lived being of some kind who
periodically steals other people's
identities by removing and magically
wearing their skin what yes let's get
into it
so what do we know about Roose Bolton is
the lord of the dreadfort head of the
old and powerful house Bolton and now
warden of the north after betraying the
Starks he's the father of Ramsay Bolton
and used to have another true born son
dimeric who according to Roose was an
all-around top bloke until Ramsay killed
his half-brother with poison
allegedly we know the ruse is
manipulative cold ambitious and utterly
ruthless we know he has an enthusiasm
for flame and leeches and is generally a
seriously creepy dude but is he an
ancient skin stealing monster the
natural first reaction to this theory is
to dismiss it as crazy and it is crazy
but is it more crazy than dragons
hundred-year-old psychic tree people ice
on bees and stone zombies
mind-controlled giant wolves necromancy
10-year winters a magic horn that roasts
your innards accurate prophecies
resurrection magical disguises faceless
men mammoths riding giants attacking a
700 foot 12 wall made of ice and if the
show is to be believed fireball throwing
skeleton monster fighting Elf children
probably not in fact the faceless man of
Braavos definitively showed that it is
possible to magically wear someone
else's skin as an effective disguise of
the whole body the men literally remove
the skin of people's faces and wear them
in a magical process that involves
cutting their own face resulting in a
disguise that have seemed to be wholly
convincing it seems to be a form of
blood magic which we've seen on a number
of times to be very real magic so we
know that something like this is
possible and if it's possible you'd
think the Bolton's would know about it
they've been flame people for centuries
so you think of anyone would discover
this magic of blood and skin they would
hells they could have gotten on a boat
and found out from the faceless men
themselves like alia does they're
practically neighbours with Braavos in
any case it seems totally plausible that
some kind of blood magic could be used
by the Bolton's to create convincing
disguises from the skins of their flayed
enemies which by the way they already
wear as clothes Roose Bolton nor the
creature wearing Grizz Bolton's skin who
for the sake of convenience will call
Bruce could be doing this what about the
other part could Roose have been hopping
between identities of centuries could he
be immortal well we certainly do have
examples of immortal or at least very
long-lived creatures in fact one of
these possibilities is particularly
relevant Roose Bolton is described as
pale and cold
and almost all of his appearances in the
books mention his strange pale eyes
Roose Bolton resembles another but how
could respond tan be a white Walker or
something like one well a possible
explanation could be found in one of old
Nan's stories now while we are yet to
see snacks or grumpkins a lot of what
old man says has been pretty accurate
like this stuff about wildlings and
remember that the others themselves were
supposedly just a story more and more of
the supernatural and mythical is turning
out to be real so it seems reasonable
that we can learn from old man stories
anyway the story goes that there was
once a man who loved a woman with skin
as white as the moon and eyes like blue
stars
she's pretty clearly another or
something of the sort and the man who
nun says might have been a Bolton gave
his seed and his soul to the woman
perhaps a child was born of this union
and given the importance of blood in A
Song of Ice and Fire and it's granting
of certain powers the child of a man in
another might have a longer life might
have blue or otherwise strange eyes he
might just generally seem really creepy
Roose Bolton may be some kind of half
human half other if not the night's king
himself wearing human skin so he have a
possible explanation for skin stealing
and a possible explanation for the
longevity and eyes and creepiness this
really does seem possible but is there
any direct evidence not really there is
this passage Roose Bolton space is a
pale gray mask with two chips of dirty
ice where his eyes should be that fits
perfectly with a theory right his skin
is a mask his eyes are ice but it could
be no more than poetic language to say
that his face and eyes are emotionless
and give nothing away and a harsh but
there is more stuff that makes a lot of
sense with this theory did you ever
wonder why Druce puts up with let alone
legitimizes the psychotic and
unpredictable Ramsay ruse implies that
the only reason he doesn't kill Ramsay
for murder and gamma Rick was because
that would be kin slaying does the man
who breaks guests write to betray and
slaughter his allies really care about
kin slain and if he needs an heir
couldn't he and Walder just have a child
who's you know less bad for PR this
theory gives Rousseau reason to keep her
home Z around Roose plans to take
Ramsay's skin and identity I mean he'd
need to change bodies eventually right
so people don't get suspicious has
resented these 50s and 60s and onwards
without visibly aging Ramsay is a
perfect candidate once legitimized
Ramsay becomes the heir of the dreadfort
and the
north and further his eyes are said to
look like roses this is important
because if Ramsey's eyes suddenly
changed a truces distinctive white like
eyes people could get suspicious and we
know from this passage that they must be
very distinctive another possible
meaning is that the other like eyes
indicate that ramsay like rouge has some
degree of other nurse and bruce wants to
keep him around for that reason either
way if Bruce has an interest in pale
eyed Ramsey being his heir maybe Roose
killed dimeric I mean poison hardly
seems to be Ramsay's style right
maybe this bastard is innocent after all
maybe Roose killed these other children
as well for lacking his strange pale
eyes another thing that this theory
explains is roses use of leeches we know
from coal towns that once the heart has
ceased to beat a man's blood runs down
into his extremities where it thickens
and congeals causing his hands and feet
to swell up and turn as black as pudding
bruce says the frequently chings are the
secret of a long life a man must purge
himself of bad blood he could be
leeching to prevent his conspicuous
condition from setting in all right so
I've got an idea of the theory let's
quickly look at an objection to it it
could be argued that it's a bit
inconsistent for is Bolton to be a
supernatural evil monster rather than a
human monster a Song of Ice and Fire
exposed the nature and reality of human
evil it's not about good guys fighting
evil monsters it's about complex human
beings who do wrong for love and to
belong and to deal with their brokenness
and as a result of a harsh world as well
as for plain psychotic madness isn't
that cheapened by having evil explained
by making someone an inhuman monster one
problem with his argument is that we
already have the others right there are
supernatural seemingly evil monsters in
A Song of Ice and Fire Roose is just
another other right and perhaps not even
that much of an evil one Roose is cruel
to his people but that maintains a
peaceful land or quiet people it works
as for the red wedding that ends a war
that otherwise would have caused far
more death and destruction and misery
than ever occurs of the twins we've
never had a point of view chapter with
Ruiz or meta Uluru so we have not a
chance to see things from his or its
point of view perhaps this monster is
more human than some of the humans we've
seen in the song after all the point is
that things may be more complicated than
they seem and so it's probably too early
to declare this theory inconsistent with
the themes of a song of us
and even if it is who gives a grumpkins
ice it's cool let's send their ball Tom
does seem plausible but there isn't any
hugely compelling evidence either way so
all these vague hints could well amount
to nothing more than a red or creepily
pale herring either way it's fun to
think about so thanks for watching this
video let me know what you want to say
next
you